[Music]
this is a three-and-a-half-hour for our
guess I feel like you right it's like a
four-hour talk that I'm doing in 30
minutes so yeah so Chris regularly thank
you for having me super excited I'm
based in San Francisco started this
company pipeline i/o about nine months
ago we spent a lot of time talking about
GPUs and all kinds of fun stuff so let
me see here this is introductions yeah
former Netflix former data bricks the
spark people I have this advanced spark
tensorflow meetup I want to talk about
this stuff real quick just because
there's way more resources right that
are out there we have a London chapter
there's actually upcoming events we've
got to meet up coming up over at the
hotels calm right like they're one of my
violent users for five line i/o so
hosting I think the 23rd we yeah just
got the email today it'll be an expanded
version of this you'll have GPUs I found
one problem with these GPU instances oh
yeah and there's this workshop too that
I'm doing coming up
yeah you guys software engineers data
scientists hopefully know a thing or two
about tensorflow we're not going to get
through like nearly like yes any of this
material but I want to give you guys
some already spun them up we're all
going to get a GPU and this is the
Google GPUs yes not the Amazon ones but
if these new Google ones that you can
attach to your CPU what I realized about
20 minutes ago when I was sitting in the
session right before is that the
instances the CPU instance is that
Google gives me in this region right
like don't have rightly avx2 and all
that kind of stuff on it so how do I
spun them up the short of it is that
things like tensor board aren't going to
work we I don't think any of the tensor
flow things will actually work but like
we can talk through that
and since I already spawned them up you
can kind of poke around so yeah grab
your IP address from it's just a simple
REST API and then go to that and just
kind of see how far you can get the
username is root I'm going to tear these
things down so fast you guys won't even
be out the door yet they're going to be
done because I'm paying for these myself
so yeah so right when like 30 minutes
are over
yeah don't expect them to be there
anymore just use route yeah
the title of talk is I guess right like
high performance like tensorflow so what
I'm going to do is kind of blaze through
some of these slides since these
notebooks aren't aren't really gonna
like it
too far things like half precision
things like this right that are now
available on the like P 100 this is the
ability to actually cram in to a
floating-point 16 into one like floating
point 32 laying on the GPUs right
because anyone's done any true to
programming sure yeah a couple people is
it as barbaric as I mean yeah you guys
find it barbaric as I just see I guess
as barbaric maybe I forgot what's funny
I think this joke is that the Nvidia
guys give us great tools to debug in
profile our shitty code that we write in
crude a fret like where they could just
make it less easy to write shitty code
if they gave us right
but like the goes been there for a while
yeah there's look like Eclipse plugins
and the Nvidia profilers and things like
that but if you're doing right like
hardcore CUDA programming right like you
really have to know your hardware specs
and what you're dealing with right so
like one thing that we will be able to
do here is actually do the first part
which is just CUDA coding so yeah we're
in demonstrate CUDA streams Krita
streams let you do right like async sort
of overlapping and so this is really
important when you start dealing with
tensor flow cues right
yeah so you're talking about that at the
very end of the talk these cues are
super important if you're using feed
dipped right now you're just just stop
just stop doing it it's like using
collecting spark right like it's in all
the examples but no
but if you start typing it just stop
yeah so start using cues especially for
GPUs you want to saturate these GPUs
yeah these cues give you the ability to
actually pull in parallel and because of
these streams right like you can
actually get that data to the GPU and
it's going to sit there waiting and so
right when it's done right like with the
previous batch it'll start on that like
next batch that's sitting there waiting
so if you're using feed dick that has to
get serialized you know especially from
python to see it's it's a right like
synchronous kind of single threaded I
think that they're working on feed dict
is what someone told me just I think
yesterday the tentacle engineers because
so many people don't even really know
about queues and queues are you know
like a little bit wonky to code they're
trying to make the actual just normal
feed dict a lot more parallel and things
like that so yeah so all these is all
open source
yeah these notebooks are all out there
the same docker image that like we're
all using is out there as well too so
you can just navigate to this but if you
guys have your instance up yeah we can
actually go see here if I can actually
yes I'm going to skip right like the
CUDA stuff but it's it like basically
shows you if you do it the old crappy
way without streams and then if you do
with the new nice way with streams Yeah
right like you get some like performance
gains there it's basically trying to
move memory in parallel right in and out
of that GPU C training devices yeah keep
an eye out for these new excel a CPU
device and I like the excel a GPU I'm
going to talk a little bit about the
excel i stuff this is the excel the
accelerated linear algebra framework
right by done sir yeah so by Google and
there's there's two big projects on top
of it there's the JIT compiler and
there's the actual äôt compiler right
and so both of these super important for
rarely performance and what you can do
is during training is that you can
actually instead of assigning it to a
CPU or GPU right you to actually say
assign it to an excel a underscore CPU
or GPU and then that's a hint to the
tensorflow compiler the to write like
try to like get these things together
you know fusing operators that kind of
stuff
tense word I believe is busted because
of the like AVX thing yeah so what
happened was because this is a
performance class I turned on all the
flags that like tensorflow has right so
I turn on all the intel optimizations
all the GPU optimizations everything
possible and yes amazon in some regions
rightly doesn't support it i found all
those issues but yeah not until this is
my third or fourth region with google
and yeah this is the one gave me
problems so maybe get on Google's case
for that yeah I believe someone asked us
today and like your talked about right
like hdfn if if you're trying to get to
you right like your existing HDFS data
so there's this this it's a top-level
project off of tensorflow it's called
ecosystem and yeah this has things for
like kubernetes HDFS spark integration
meso stalker yeah so no more feed dick
just forget about that use cues like the
codes a little bit wonky ER but you're
right like definitely in a saturated see
you and I like GPUs yes also these cues
aren't just cues right like they're not
just like sitting there with data
they're actually really capable of doing
right like pre-processing so you know
picture this pipeline where you have to
like crop images and you want to relics
cue them and kind of really show the
network different views of a specific
image right these things can be handled
by the queues themselves and there's
like shuffling queues that'll just
randomly shuffle yeah so this is stuff
that like right like you don't have to
code yourself so I'd done yes I mean
opposed fees also they're not in the
current Riley GPU ml repo but they will
be probably on the flight back tomorrow
there's a notebook to this notebook work
anyone try to get this one to work paid
cue number two
censor flow model I'm going to see me
guys know this stuff now that you guys
know about the debugger
yeah that sounds flow debugger this yeah
this is pretty snazzy you wrap your
tensor flow session in this debugger
session and it gives you the ability to
actually step through and see tensors
and it's it it like looks like this like
horrible command line thing right but
you can actually write like use your
mouse and kind of click back and forth
and it's kind of fun it's like the
craziest like like ASCII command line
tool there's more of these coming out of
like Google to that right like you start
seeing kind of flow through rightly pull
requests and things like that
so especially for like the excel a stuff
there's like a few things that they
haven't like released yet that I've been
hearing about
alright so distributed tensor flow the
whole reason tensor flow is popular at
least in my opinion is the distributed
nature of it right so it's it's just
like anything like when you first get
your you know spark cluster you first
start working with spark single node and
then like right this is great but now
I'm a big data set now what do I do
yeah so Google doesn't do anything
single node obviously right the problem
with distributed sensor flow is that
it's not very well documented it's been
changing really quite a bit there's huge
huge API changes that are even coming in
right like 1 1 or 1/2 with any
distributed system right there's
failures there's different types of node
failures there's certain right like
nodes that are more rare like
specialized and like the master and the
chief and things like that and right
like the term zookeeper starts popping
up and everyone gets all freaked out
right but so yeah oh yeah this is
actually single node multi-gpu
just real quick on this the CPU sir to
acts like a parameter server right so
this is one node but you kind of write
like give the CPU sort of the dumbest
task which is just store these values
and then pass right like the more
complex matrix multiplies rightly to the
GPU to rally each GPU and then they send
it back and then
right yeah so that's CPU just does like
an average or a you know some something
like that and then like rebroadcast out
those gradients but the actual GPUs
themselves are what's doing the right
like the complex stuff so now this is
more general this is across nodes the
left here is single node if you do
switch then that same code you would
switch over to be multi node yeah so
tensor flow starts to add these send to
receive things right yeah so you don't
have to worry about those yourself but
yeah those become nodes inside of your
graph and we're like have like that
responsibility using G RPC and then this
is a parameter server here so right like
similar to the CPU thing except this is
a cluster of servers whose job it is to
just maintain these values and to just
do the averaging for the gradients and
then broadcast out right
there's synchronous the right there's
asynchronous where certain right like
nodes could be operating on older values
because they're they're you know slower
I like things like that so yeah you have
to like start to make trade-offs there
there's the synchronous asynchronous
yeah so there's data parallel versus
model parallel the one that we're
probably most familiar with is data
parallel and so that's how SPARC works
right you take a data set you split it
up and each node has the same graph the
same model and it's just going to write
like take the data that it sees
hopefully shuffled it's going to then
calculate the gradient and then send it
back for the model parallel this is you
know super large models that won't fit
inside of one GPU rattly memory right
because these are 12 gig or really
possibly 16 gigs something like that so
for that like you can only put parts of
that same model right like you have to
split the model up and then each worker
then sees all the data but has just one
part of the model
yeah
so the Excel a it's pretty experimental
yeah even when right like tensorflow is
working for these demos things get a
little wonky in this area there's ways
to work around it but let's see yeah the
whole goal here is like to basically
fuse things together fuse operators
right like similar to spark right like
I've talked a lot about spark because of
data bricks and right like my
experiences there and just watching that
project evolve but you know think of
like the ability to combine MapReduce so
like right like link spark first came
out it was known it was better than to
do because it would take the map it
would take the filter it would rightly
put them on the same node rightly
possibly and not have to actually write
data to disk and pull it up and do all
the intermediate things like that in
spark zero they actually break apart
right the map on the filter and they
physically create one Java function
right there's this project called
Jeanine oh that can take a string and
then actually compile it on the fly and
so that becomes now your new virtue
right like this new function it's going
to cache write that like class file or
that function or whatever so that's not
constantly being rebuilt but so that way
you just polling memory once and then
you can just kind of rip through all the
data and so you're not right like
putting data back into RAM and then
pulling it back so it sort of build on
top of like the same pattern I'm not
having to go to disk so if you're not
pulling from like main memory that
data's in the registers this concept of
the hlo so think yeah this is yeah so
terms right like LLVM should sound
familiar where it's sort of an
intermediate representation right so the
kind of simplest way to think of it is
like a logical plan right that gets
converted into a physical plan that's
targeted to rally the actual hardware
that your queries run on right
right now there's GPU Envy PTX support
that's the instruction set for the
nvidia gpus arm of course the android
devices and then x86 the cpu instruction
sets and so there's this whole host of
oh so for the excellet stuff there's I
think I have a reference in the actual
like notebook on this that has all of
the operations right and and it's ways
to fuse things together and quite like
all the fancy stuff that's going on here
so just in time compiler build on top of
the excel a framework so this is during
training time for example this is
similar to what I just described with
spark it's going to unroll loops and you
know constant folding and all the
classic so yeah this is so that yeah
here's an example of when you place just
a simple you know squaring and you yeah
so this is the actual assembly that that
was generated it's much much tighter
than if you didn't do that and then
here's a like visualization there's a
lab on this out there as well - that's
this is the snippet of code that
actually creates these things and then
you could use right like the goop right
like the Google web tracing framework to
actually render it so this code
puts it into a format that is this
timeline thing so you can actually see
here there's a bunch of operations right
that all get like jutted into one excel
a blob so this is huge right this is
huge performance gains there's another
visualization this is all right like
tooling that's available if you look at
this notebook just kind of look at the
comments whatever you'll see from this
point on we're in yeah how much time do
I have
I've like two seconds oh I do oh [ __ ]
just slow it down so from this point on
this is going to beat Riley mostly
inference talk so this is right like the
prediction side of things so yeah these
are optimizations now that model has
been trained and and yeah so there's
certain things that like we can do to
actually make the prediction side faster
so this is where the Riley äôt side of
this comes into play so for example so
picture this model has been built and
now we want to just try to minimize the
actual runtime that gets pulled in right
so you can pass into the excel a
framework there's this TF compile
command until it right like where to
start with your node which is typically
the right like the input that your feet
again right because you're predicting
and then you give it the fetch side of
things which is the actual prediction
and so tensorflow can go through and
figure out what's the bare minimum right
yeah so from the actual tensorflow
runtime which kernels do I need right to
actually pull in and that's all it's
going to pull in right and now the
tensile runtime itself is not that large
I think it's 20 mega 3d Meg but if you
can shrink it down to you know right
like 600 K which is one example from I
think it was one and a half Meg model
plus your 30 Meg runtime but they yes
with this TF compile you can actually
strip all that away and really just have
a final binary that's 600 okay so yeah
this gets packaged up as a CC library
it's got a header file object file you
can link to it and this is commonly used
on these embedded devices things like
that currently there there is no GPU
support this is basically because a lot
of these small devices don't have GPUs
so there there hasn't been a lot of
right like effort put into that okay so
the graph transform tool is is pretty
sweet this thing so during training
right there's all these notes right
there's the send/receive nodes that I
showed there's nodes that are logging
that
that are poor right like for tensor
board right because like tensor board
yeah so periodically like you're writing
out really how's my loss function doing
here
probably compared to my like test
validation I like that kind of stuff so
yes all of those things get stripped out
right like there's yeah so that's pretty
obvious there's certain things like drop
out right so drop out this yes so this
is only there at training time now some
people might be thinking well when you
do the infrared side of things don't you
have to adjust for that and yes you do
and so tensorflow does this trick where
it will actually boost right so the the
final value that that gets frozen dryly
into this model has boosted values on on
the the non dropped out right like
probably connections right so normally
you would think of it as those
connections are dropped and then
everything stays the same but yeah it
sounds are full of boosts it's so that
you don't have to maintain which ones
were dropped out yeah because that would
be way too much overhead so yeah keep an
eye on up there's a right like the like
classic drop off paper does not talk
about that and so that's why I like you
have to kind of combine that with some
of the documentation that's in like
tensorflow which is confusing until you
realize that trick that they're doing
with the boosting on the other sides of
those rightly dropped out connections
yeah so things like batch normalization
you should always be using Bachelor
Malaysian by the way because we're doing
mini batch gradient descent here right
like we're not training on whether each
piece of data because that's too small
and like we're not training on the
entire dataset because that's too big
right so we're doing mini batches
because these things are getting
shuffled randomly they could be all over
the place right so one problem right
that these networks have is that like
they have to see this distribution which
could be wildly rightly changing rarely
depending on and so Bachelor
mobilization help shrink that down helps
Riley converge quicker and train faster
and there's basically no reason to not
use it so when you're done what you can
do is actually burn those weights in
right those like pre calculated weights
that word
learned from this batch normalization
rarely processed through the training
process and so like you don't actually
have to do those matrix multiplies again
you can just probably calculate them
once and then burn them into the final
model for the inference side things like
quantization this is pretty cool there's
a lot of examples on this so Google
bought this guy's company Pete worden
who I think is actually based or was
based here probably still is based here
yeah he is really it's probably the best
blog post on this kind of stuff he's a
guy that actually built the graph
transform tool when he came to Google he
had kind of this like loose collection
of things and like people started to
write their own post training
optimizations and so he decided to go
make this framework called the graph
transform tool that like you can then
hook into and but yeah weight
quantization this is yeah so once you've
actually trained the model right like
now you know all the weights and like
you can kind of fit them all in so right
like you're going to lose precision here
of course but it I mean this it like
greatly reduces the size in fact the
notebooks actually we take a 32k model
just a simple model linear regression we
run via the Reilly 8-bit quantization
and it goes down to I think like 13 K
and that's just just like simple just
like a pass through boom it's basically
taking all the floats as it sees and
slotting them into these 256 8-bit slots
right and because you know this whole
deep learning stuff's all fuzzy anyway
it's still works out right yeah that's
the thing
there's yes activation quantization this
is not as easy as doing that because
those values aren't known right like the
activation side of things the input
right this is like dependent on the
inputs so when you're trying to quantize
this part of it what you need to do is
actually calibrate pull some data that's
right like most representative of the
data set this is yeah that's the right
like tricky part right there it's not a
lot of data though and so you pass it
through and now right
you can quantize based on right like the
values that it sees from I like the
inputs and then we're like the output
like activation here's a quick visual of
so this is yeah so it's just finding min
and Max and then smashing them into the
right like negative 128 it's like
positive 127 batch normalization you
always use it yeah and so the graph
transform tool this is a you know first
class transformation here takes the you
know final mean final variance and
sticks it in and and really pre
calculates all the weights here okay we
have a couple minutes left
yeah so no one rarely ever gets around
to talking about time scale of serving
because it's always the last part of and
I thought about actually like doing it
first but yeah we would have missed all
that stuff with like the graph
transforms and things like that but the
key takeaway here is to use like request
batching and so I think I have an image
of it here see if there's anything on
this slide yes one thing about sensible
serving that changed like dramatically
with like times flow one oh is the
actual model format so before you know
there was like this export format and
then you know had these check point
files and have files everywhere and you
know dot Like dot metafiles and just
seemed like an endless and yeah so now
for the serving side of things and this
is starting to propagate through to the
training stuff as well
you actually like save the model and
it's just called I think it's just
called save model dot PB which is rarely
protobuf oh yeah so I should mention too
that like tensorflow stores the graph
separately because that's static that's
actual architecture right that's your
dag and then has the variable separate
because you can pull those variables in
again those weights and start to train
again right yeah which is something that
probably was discussed yesterday as well
so yeah that pattern still what happens
yeah yeah okay there's a lot of really
cool temps flow serving features so when
I first started pipeline I we had
thought about doing our own tensorflow
serving engine right and just kind of
bypassing Google oh yeah like like
they're just throwing something out
there just just to keep you know people
happy or whatever and this project has
lagged behind sense flow itself it's
always kind of a question if you do get
the new tensorflow is this potential
serving still going to compile you know
things like that they've gotten a tiny
bit better
but if you go look at the Stars for
example I think there's only like 15 or
2,000 stars on ten Souls surveying
there's like I just checked there's like
56,000 on like tensorflow so but like to
me this is the most interesting right
because think of how many people use
tensorflow serving oh it's it's right
like all of the users that are using
like right like your system so whereas
tensorflow training side of things is
just the it's just the data scientists
it's just the actual people in your
group so in terms of right like big oh
right like this stuff's a lot more
interesting at least to me anyway so
yeah I've combined some of my Netflix
experience you know with like circuit
breakers and fallbacks and all those
kind of stuff but yeah so back to this
tensile serving stuff with Google they
keep announcing more and more things and
and I keep seeing right these like pull
requests that come in that are like 900
files and it's like it's you know it's
just got one comments right and it says
like we're finally making this public
and it's this huge experimentation
framework and you know a/b testing and
I'm like alright well if I'd spent the
last six months building that that that
would have been a complete waste of time
so you see you know one or two of those
and you're just like all right I'm just
going to you know wrap this thing figure
out how to that like use it so
fortunately they've split it out not
sure if I guy so that's like it there's
there's one server core where like who's
like C++ file that you can include and
then you gain access to all of the
goodies but that just changed
few months prediction service the
original prediction service was just
predict you passed in tensors you you've
got out tensors they've now added
classified at right they've had a
regression what you're starting to see
is a cloud ml which is their product
right there right like service that is
using like tensor flow right like
features come out on that shortly after
you see them kind of right like pop up
in the open source stuff right so they
make API changes huge API changes to
tensor flow surveying and huge
experimentation frameworks because
they're using it right and yeah so they
want you to start using these example
classes for example this was like the
worst name for a but yes I guess that's
what they're called right examples if
you like speak about it casually people
like oh it's example code I'd I could
pay attention but this is actually a
super cork right like component to the
new like sensor flow stuff here so yeah
so they had to classify the added right
like the regression stuff and then of
course these things show up as
first-class citizens within cloud ml
which is not surprising but just just
kind of funny to note there are thing
that change their signature deaths so
one big thing here is that when you used
to use tensor field surveying you had to
know the actual physical name of the
input node of the feed node right and
that that could be named anything it can
be first named anything by the actual
person creating right that graph that's
actually training the graph but then it
could get munched and have a colon zero
or a colon one depending on if you know
right like there's other variable names
that just have to be in scope at the
time so it was always kind of a
crapshoot like did I get the right name
for the inputs and so now there's the
sort of logical thing right that doesn't
change and when and when someone hands
you this model they keep the logical one
the same hopefully and they've done the
mapping on the inside yeah so there's
this method like build sensor info that
actually takes right like whatever name
it is at that point right like you never
have to know
yeah multi had an inference this was
another thing that we had talked about a
little bit yes sort of internally and
then all of a sudden boom yeah Google
has this so this is one pass in and you
could do both regression and both
classification and that data comes in
just once and you save a lot
here's that server core that you can
import if one do your own
yeah the request batching so this yes we
use this quite a bit at write like
Netflix when we have so much data coming
in so many people asking you know for
the metadata for some movie or some TV
show and so picture these are separate
requests coming in right separate
requests if you can kind of wait you
know 10 milliseconds right that's the
batch timeout right and then just batch
them all up you can pad with zeroes you
wouldn't really do that but you know
sort of logically build up a big matrix
from these you know smaller matrix
multiplies make one big matrix multiply
pass it to the GPU pull it back and
because right like you know the offsets
it's the same result and right like that
goes back to that client which could be
anywhere in the world and that goes back
to the other one so it's an obvious
trade-off between throughput and latency
huge huge performance gains there if you
have low throughput don't use it because
you'll probably always have a 10
millisecond pause and that's it fast
I've ever gotten through that Wow
any questions do we have time for
questions like what's that interesting
was it yes I have a question was it
interesting was it what you were
expecting
yeah yeah the question is so this would
be back to the äôt stuff probably right
the TF compile where the best blog to
look for that stuff is that guy Pete
Pete worden w AR D en I think it's just
people
it's like Pete were calm and he has all
the specs in there yeah the big thing
there too is the size right just the the
pure size of your stripping out nodes
you know of course so the forward prop
right because like when you're training
its forward prop and back prop forward
drop and then back prop I think I was
doing that on the right but when it's on
right like the inference prediction side
it's just forward problem so you want to
reduce the number of you know yeah
that's a good question yeah
yeah yeah yeah I mean it's yeah it's the
classic so I think it's the classic
question of how do you know what is
representative and so what you would do
is is not quantize right just you know
just take the slow model and it's yeah
and just basically validate on the in
yeah so compare the slow model to the to
this newly quantized model that's been
recalibrated and just keep an eye on
that right because you know the accuracy
of of the old model that like has now
been quantized and then you go and then
recalibrate it and then quantize it and
just compare the accuracy if it's wildly
often you've chosen a dataset that's not
that isn't able to generalize yeah and
it's chosen these these normalized
weights that are way off yeah are these
activations yeah I mean yeah yeah I
don't have anything more than that just
it's really knowing your you know domain
and that kind of thing right yeah
mm question is if I have a spark project
how do i is there any benefit to moving
to tensorflow right I mean yeah this is
this is every single person I that I
talked to is like going through this
exact same thing right and the you know
big barrier obviously is there's not a
like a whole lot of real-world examples
of tensorflow
you know that are out there like we're
starting to see more and like Google
certainly did a really good job by
giving us examples and you know like
like rightly complex examples to write
like the emne stand right like CFR and
all that stuff not just kind of toy
examples but I mean yeah I always just
kind of recommend you spark for ETL man
and get it into HDFS get it anywhere and
then rip through it which sounds fun
yeah so yeah thanks
[Applause]
[Music]